Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
À 15 ans,
j’étais plongé en pleine révolution.
Le régime syrien et l’armée sont là.
Nous, mes amis, moi
et les gens [inaudible],
on réclamait la liberté,
la dignité, la justice et la démocratie.
Eux, ils nous tiraient dessus.
J'ai reçu deux balles dans la main.
Je pensais qu'on allait
m'emmener à l'hôpital.
Mais on m'a amené en prison.
Dans une cellule
avec plus de 50 personnes.
J’étais souvent obligé
de me soigner tout seul.
À un moment donné,
j’ai souhaité mourir.
Mais j’ai survécu.
J’avais besoin de me comprendre,
de m’exprimer,
de traduire mes sentiments.
J’ai pris cette photo avec cette main
qu’un jour j’ai failli perdre.
En couvrant la guerre,
jour après jour, j’ai travaillé
avec certaines agences.
J’ai gagné des prix
que je n’avais jamais rêvé avoir.
Ce qu’on voit sur l’écran,
c’était des moments
et des jours banals pour nous.
Le seul moment qui n’était pas banal,
c’est quand le gouvernement
nous a obligés à partir.
Fin 2016.
Voilà comment je suis venu en Europe
et comment j’ai recommencé
une nouvelle vie à Paris
à 21 ans.
J’ai acheté mon premier livre :
« Comment apprendre le français
en trois semaines sans professeur ».
Le lendemain, je suis allé
dans un restaurant
et en toute confiance,
j’ai dit au serveur :
« Je suis poulet et un Coca-Cola,
s’il vous plaît. »
C’est à ce moment-là
que je me suis rendu compte
que j’avais besoin d’un vrai professeur
et de plus que trois semaines
pour apprendre la langue.
Lorsque je marchais dans la rue,
à chaque fois que j’entendais
le bruit d’un avion,
je me cachais sans réfléchir.
Les gens me regardaient bizarrement.
Ils ne savaient pas ce que ce bruit
voulait dire pour moi.
À cette époque-là,
le magazine Polka m’a proposé de faire
une formation de photographie de deux ans
dans une école qui s’appelle Spéos.
J’étais tellement motivé
que je me suis préparé toute la semaine.
Puis, un jour, on m’a appelé
à 11 heures du matin
pour demander pourquoi je n’étais pas là.
Sérieusement ?
Je n’avais pas réalisé
qu’on était déjà lundi.
En Syrie, on ne comptait pas les jours.
Pendant la guerre,
ils étaient tous pareils.
Quelques jours plus tard,
une camarade est venue me parler.
Elle m’a demandé ce que
je pensais de Poutine.
Elle est totalement élégante
que je me suis demandé si Poutine
n’était pas une marque de vêtements.
Dans la langue arabe,
on n’a pas la lettre P.
Voilà comment j’ai appris l’anglais,
le français et surtout la lettre P.
Grâce à mon école,
j’ai commencé à faire d’autres genres
de photographies en France.
Aujourd’hui, je suis bien entouré,
j’ai un grand groupe d’amis.
Ce groupe d’amis a pris une place
importante dans ma vie,
cette place qui appartenait
aux autres amis en Syrie.
J’aurais souhaité garder les deux
dans ma vie.
Ce groupe d’amis était les Casques blancs.
Ils étaient pharmacien,
étudiant, ancien cuisinier,
et beaucoup d’autres professions encore.
Trente personnes ont créé ce groupe
afin de sauver la vie des autres.
Je les accompagnais en tant que
photographe dans ma ville natale, Alep.
Dans cette ville, tu commences ta journée
en t’attendant à ce que
quelqu’un perde la vie.
Si rien ne se passe,
ta journée sera anormale.
J’ai entretenu une relation forte
avec Bibars.
Pendant trois ans,
on partait dans la même voiture à chaque
fois qu’il y avait des bombardements.
Sur le chemin, nos cœurs battaient fort
alors que les avions volaient
au-dessus de nos têtes.
On se regardait à chaque fois
comme si c’était la dernière.
À Alep,
la vie pouvait s’arrêter à chaque fois.
En acceptant que la mort peut frapper
à tout moment,
on peut donc profiter de chaque instant
comme si c’était le dernier.
Salam, [inaudible] de théâtre, elle nous
obligeait à rire, quoi qu’il arrive.
On chantait, on plaisantait,
on vivait à fond.
Mais ça ne changeait rien à la guerre.
Ce groupe a aussi payé le prix fort.
Plusieurs ont été blessés.
Certains ont trouvé la mort.
Parmi eux,
celui dont j’étais le plus proche,
mon père.
Salam a disparu depuis notre
déplacement forcé fin 2016.
Bibars
fait toujours partie
des Casques blancs en Syrie.
Moi,
je suis là.
Je me suis retrouvé sur le tournage
du « Petit Nicolas » en 2020.
C’est ici que j’ai découvert
la force du cinéma,
le pouvoir de l’art, la possibilité
d’aller au-delà du réel.
Ce film a été tourné
au milieu de nulle part.
La plupart des acteurs
étaient des enfants.
Notamment celui
qui jouait le petit Nicolas.
En les photographiant jour après jour,
j’ai eu un flashback des photos
que j’avais prises il y a cinq ans.
Celle d’enfants qui jouaient
à faire la guerre.
La guerre est un film réel.
Le film le plus lent
que j’aie jamais photographié.
Ce qui est triste et ironique à la fois,
c’est que je continue toujours,
même en France,
à documenter les drames et les violences.
En novembre 2020,
lors d’une journée normale,
je me suis réveillé tôt, je me suis fait
un café avant de partir.
On était samedi.
J’avais décidé
de couvrir une manifestation.
40 000 personnes étaient dans la rue
pour lutter contre le projet de loi
sur la sécurité globale.
Comme toujours, je parlais avec les gens
tout en prenant mes photos.
À la fin de la journée,
il y a un clash entre les manifestants
et les policiers.
Tout à coup, je me suis
retrouvé par terre.
J’entendais clairement tout le monde,
mais je ne voyais quasiment plus rien.
C’est à ce moment-là que je me suis rendu
compte que j’étais couvert de sang.
J'avais reçu un coup de matraque
en plein visage.
Je n'avais rien vu venir.
Je ne savais pas si j’avais peur.
Si.
Une peur un peu décalée.
Une question m’obsédait :
est-ce que je resterais encore beau
comme avant, comme maintenant ?
Allais-je être défiguré,
au point qu’on ne me reconnaîtrait plus ?
Est-ce que j’allais m’offrir
un café le lendemain,
trois mois, trois ans plus tard ?
J’avais déjà posé cette même question
dix ans en arrière.
Je ne savais même pas imaginer ce
que serait ma vie avec une seule main.
Je m’appelle Ameer, j’ai 25 ans.
J’ai vécu des moments remarquables
pendant la guerre en Syrie.
J’ai également fui la mort plusieurs fois.
J’ai vécu la vie en rose à Paris.
Je l’ai vécue en rouge aussi.
Je ne sais toujours pas
si la photo fait partie de ma vie
ou si c’est tout le temps ma vie
qui fait partie de mes photos.
Mais ce dont je suis sûr,
c’est que l’appareil photo
a toujours été mon meilleur ami,
mon confident,
et peut-être mon psychologue,
qui m’aide à me réveiller le matin,
à respirer, à partager et à sourire.
Et vous, qui vous aide à faire tout ça ?
(Applaudissements)